Amazon Prime has finally got Stargate  back in our screens in America at least  so I thought I would take this  opportunity to give you the definitive  timeline of the new series of  development and how we got from there to  here so I've been talking about a new  series of Stargate four wow a year and  we're still not on our screens I have  been able to give you lots of little  Scoops and a behind the scenes view of  what is going on in the offices of MGM  and Amazon so now it finally looks like  Amazon is taking Stargate seriously it's  put sg1 and Atlantis back on our screens  at very least in the United States and  uh I'm told in Europe and the UK very  shortly that I would take this  opportunity to give you the definitive  timeline of how the new series is being  developed and where we are right now  foreign